last tuesday tesla dropped what elon
musk claims to be
a quantum leap in full self-driving
technology
this update lays out the base for level
5 autonomy
meaning that now there is officially
greater than a 0
chance that an updated tesla can make it
from start to destination
with zero interventions despite this
many reputable news sources continue to
describe the competition
as tracking close behind so here's why
tesla is not only crushing the
competition today
but why they will continue to annihilate
the race to full self-driving
moving forward
starting off let's take a look at the
situation today
as of april 2020 tesla had a total
of 3 billion miles on autopilot
meanwhile second place goes to google's
waymo who has a total of
20 million miles as of january 2020
not only was there already a 150
times gap between first and second place
but tesla has also been exponentially
growing their lead just six months
before reaching 3 billion miles on
autopilot
tesla was just at 1.88 billion miles
since then it's likely that tesla has
further accelerated their data
collection rate
given record vehicle sales for tesla
throughout the pandemic
but even if they simply fall the same
pace they would be at
well over 4 billion total miles driven
today so
what's the secret that the rest of the
competition is missing
well the first major difference between
tesla and the competition
is their radically different fundamental
approach tesla has mostly been using
cameras to gather autonomous vehicles
while most of the competition has been
focused on getting lidar to work
lidar stands for light detection and
ranging
and it is likely the first technology
you would consider when trying to
develop an autonomous vehicle
lidar sends out light and times how long
it takes for the light to bounce off
various objects
and return to its sensors using this
information
lidar is able to essentially map out its
surroundings
cameras on the other hand simply capture
the light rays
bouncing off of its lenses it doesn't
automatically create a 3d map
or a 3d sketch of the surroundings or
anything like that
as a result it's completely up to the
programmers to figure out how to convert
a 2d image
into 3d or even 4d data that the
computer can understand
i'm honestly not really sure why tesla
decided to not use lidar
and deal with yet another obstacle in
the road to full self-driving
but here's some of the arguments that
have been presented so far
elon musk has often pointed out that
humans don't have lasers shooting
from our heads in all directions when
we're driving
we simply have two cameras and are for
the most part
able to drive exceptionally of course we
have plenty of
unfortunate crashes every single year
but
these are virtually all due to lapses in
judgment as opposed to not having enough
data
thus the argument suggests if two
cameras are more than enough for humans
eight cameras should be overkill in
terms of data for ai
personally i still don't fully
understand why they can't use both
to cross-reference data especially when
lidar has gotten cheap enough to be
included in smartphones
moreover it's not like teslas are
completely free of radars
and completely dependent on cameras only
anyways
so this might just be a case of elon
musk defending what he originally
claimed
but that's beside the point anyways
though more difficult to implement
tesla has over the years built up their
system to rival lidar systems
and today cameras have enabled them to
destroy ladder dependent systems
in terms of interpretation lidar may
have greater accuracy
in terms of mapping out their
surroundings to this day
but cameras have proven to be invaluable
when it comes to
actually understanding surrounding data
for instance if you come across a
parking lot on the side of the road
both systems would recognize the
obstacle but
ladder based systems don't exactly
understand what the obstacle is
meanwhile tesla's cameras know that a
line of cars on the side of the road
is the same thing as a line marking more
importantly
tesla's system also knows that a line of
cars
means that it should potentially
anticipate someone backing out
so though i believe tesla would have
benefited from
also implementing lidar their focus on
cameras was spot on
as this allows their cars to actually
interpret what's going on around them
as opposed to just differentiating
between obstacles and
not obstacles thus the first major
benefit for tesla
is their exponentially better
interpretation system
moving on we have the actual processing
of this information
google along with other key competitors
have placed a brunt of their efforts
into precisely mapping out various
cities for a while now
google has been sending out mapping cars
which are very similar to google maps
street view cars
but these mapping cars are way more
precise and collect much more data
the mapping cards capture everything
around them
down to a centimeter all of the lane
merges the traffic lights
the traffic signs the fire hydrant
everything
once the data collection is done their
regular self-driving cars can start
driving on these roads
with no problem whatsoever but
here's the thing this is not really
self-driving
yes that cars are driving themselves
however there is very little cognition
involved in the process
google self-driving cars are simply
comparing what they scan
to what the mapping cars previously
scanned as you can see
this requires significantly less
artificial intelligence
and requires constant updating to keep
the system fully working
this might work in densely populated
urban cores
where the mapping cars can go out on a
regular basis
and constantly update the map however
in areas that are not mapped the soft
driving car
is actually not self-driving at all
conversely
tesla has focused their efforts onto
artificial intelligence
and making decisions in real time based
on what the cameras see
elon musk describes that using hd maps
is a really bad idea
as it can't change and it can't adapt
though this does provide a pretty solid
solution for the short term
he believes that this takes away from
developing truly full self-driving cars
and thus he refuses to use hd maps
as what he describes to be a crutch with
that being said
if tesla wants to develop full
self-driving without relying on hd maps
then they're going to need a lot of data
and a lot of trial and error
and that brings us on to tesla's next
big advantage
which is their extensive fleet tesla has
sold over 300
000 cars just this year and while this
is nothing compared to volkswagen
and toyota several million cars per your
sales figures this is
leagues ahead of any other autonomous
car company
general motors does have its supercrew
self-driving technology
but this technology is currently only
available
in the cadillac lineup and the fleet is
quite limited
as for waymo they only have a miniscule
fleet
of 600 cars to make things worse
google owns all of these cars and they
have to pay for the operation
of all of them aside from the small
revenue they get from their limited
ride healing service meanwhile tesla is
a very profitable company
with hundreds of thousands of cars that
are being driven for free for tesla
by pushing out self-driving to the
public tesla
has been able to employ hundreds of
thousands of people to give them free
data on a daily basis also
not only is tesla able to gather data by
letting individuals use their
self-driving technology
around the world but they're also able
to collect data
about how their hundreds of thousands of
drivers drive when self-driving is
turned off
and this is honestly even more valuable
as it allows tesla's neural network to
constantly learn from how humans drive
in scenarios where drivers have deemed
it is not safe
or efficient for self-driving to be used
when you're working towards figuring out
the tail end of self-driving technology
this information is invaluable as
it's usually very difficult if not
impossible to artificially replicate
as a result tesla's self-driving system
is able to consistently learn about
humans deal with one in a billion
and one 10 billion chance scenarios thus
completing the final parts of full
self-driving and
that brings me on to the final reason
tesla will win the race to autonomy
which is that they're just software
updates away from making full
self-driving
a reality considering that these are
just over the year updates
as opposed to selling new vehicles tesla
can easily roll out their new software
to existing customers
and as i mentioned at the start of the
video they're
already rolling out the first stage of
level 5 autonomy
right now it is just a private beta but
it is expected that
it will roll out to the general public
by the end of 2020
with their ability to simply update
their users over the year to full
self-driving
it's no question that they'll have the
easiest time introducing the technology
to the market at this point at the end
of the day
tesla has chosen a different path from
the rest of the competition
the competition has chosen to figure out
methods to make self-driving
easier for computers while tesla has
chosen to simply model self-driving
after how humans drive despite the
difficulty
as a result unlike the competition tesla
cars
interpret data like we do they analyze
data like we do
and then they try to make decisions like
we do
this in conjunction with their vast
fleet and rapid
update ability will in my opinion allow
tesla to maintain their lead in
self-driving technology
for the foreseeable future but that's
just what i think
who do you guys think will win the race
for autonomy comment that down below
and if you guys would like to propose
video ideas just like this one
then consider joining our discord
community in the description down below
our moderators have been working very
hard at building up the server
and we would like to hear about what you
guys have to say about current videos
and future videos anyways if you guys
are excited for fully autonomous cars
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on next one
[Music]
you